jetzt kommen wir jetzt das notebook
jetzt kommen wir zu unserem wichtigsten
teil den
brauchen wir haben ja geheimtipp von
ihnen wir haben so wenig zeit wir legen
die schwerpunkte so passt auf
wir haben gefragt
respekt und jetzt kommt wieder einer
frag mich was jetzt kommt erstmal einer
frage was und zwar hallo warum sehe ich
nicht warum sehe ich jetzt sami slimani
nicht das ist ja wirklich zum kotzen ich
hab's dann manchmal computer sowie gehen
erstmal auf ein anderes video
zertifikat ich hasse computer
kommt gleich wieder ruhe liegt die kraft
ich habe zeit du nicht ich nicht
davor habe ich bei diesem interview da
habe ich so schiss vor gehabt dass wir
das pensum nicht schaffen liegt aber
auch sagen was ich so viel rede auch
dass ich dir leider die zeit sozusagen
klar ja aber das ist ja gut das ist eine
gute sache nicht werden aber eine eine
verlängerung kriegst du also wenn ich
mit dir cool bin und sodann ich krieg
hat ja auf jeden fall zu einer
verlängerung okay jetzt versuchen wir es
noch mal wo ist dieser ich krieg die
krise gerade mit der technik
ich habe hier beide videos sowie zu noch
mal ganz ruhig frage für klicks um bitte
öffnen
ja die ist schon wahrscheinlich offen du
bist du nur noch auf play drücken also
nee das ist kann das ist nicht das ist
der browser hier leider das ist prima da
manchmal die fenster zu
irgend eine störung hat der moment und
unterlässt ja oder ist jetzt musst du
dir über den quicktime player laufen der
macht mir im moment kein fenster auf
deswegen beende ich erst mal die anderen
programme
ich hasse es das passiert natürlich auch
immer den besten natürlich lässt
deswegen meine angst war dass ich habe
eine lebensregel ist es muss immer etwas
schief gehen wenn vor dem interview
wobei hier so viel schief gegangen
eigentlich muss darf nichts mehr
schiefgehen also ist nichts
schiefgegangen aber immer zusage keine
zusage keine zeit für den aufbau doch
zeit von aufbau
gut weg gehen woanders hin und machen
erst die nutzer fragen vielleicht
neustart ja aber das dauert daher ein
ewig ja gut dann machst du gemacht hast
meine antwort ja er hatte ja genug zeit
werde ich antworte ich krieg die krise
ja meine damen und herren wir sind hier
live bei klicks und hier wird uns gerade
noch mal demonstriert dass auch die
großartigen moderatorin pixum nicht
unfehlbar sind aber und auch apple ist
auch noch immer das gute
also hier sehen wir auch das erste mal
nicht funktioniert
gerade gibt es morgen wieder ein patch
und dann ist wieder alles gut ja ich
weiß nicht ich weiß es nicht so ich geh
jetzt nochmal er hat scheint sich etwas
beruhigt zu haben
du hast auf 5 milliarden fenster offen
also das ist ja das ist aber eben nicht
gar kein problem fünf jahre fenster
wir haben alle zeit der welt hast du
keinen anderen player also nicht vlc
oder so ja den habe ich aber das ist
jetzt so ein gemurkse
im moment macht er nichts
eröffnet kein kein garnichts
okay ich mache einen neustart es hilft
nix in der ruhe liegt die kraft ich
wahnsinnig viel auf
und auch richtig speicher intensive aber
eigentlich ist das kein problem
der pass auf
ich mache jetzt brutal
weil das kriegen wir nicht so schnell
wendet ja
markus du musst kannst ja sagen wir
müssen 500 länger machen weil sein
hängt sich gerade auf und wir sind die
ganze zeit fünf minuten schon am video
öffnen jetzt hat der neu gestaltet also
sie muss fünf minuten dran hängen hat er
gesagt habe ich sie sollten kommt von
mir kommt von mir
bist du so machen wir das die zu den
kopf schütteln das geht wirklich nicht
dann will ich nicht sagen nein hier geht
es ja noch meister es gibt natürlich
auch leute da bin ich froh wenn ich
hatte dann raus ich denke obwohl die
gibt es eigentlich jetzt auch selten
ganz selten also ja ich gebe jetzt seit
elf den ersten wirklich jetzt interviews
am stück da sind ja schon 16 18 tage
oder so und im dezember jahr habe ich
auch schon die langfristigen internet
schreiben diesen planer wissen und da
war eigentlich alles okay also ich hab
jetzt von 50 interviews und bei zwei
zweigen gedacht so echt ist steht mit
der stunde schreibt da hätte auch deine
kleine tochter schreiben können ja dann
nervt mich doch welche stunden hätte er
schickt mir eine e-mail frage deutet
sage ich dir ja oder nein oder nicht
aber ich mit der eine stunde und auf
einmal kommt also blödsinn da raus und
ich denke wer bist du denn jetzt gerade
eigentlich
so und wir kommen diese frage von sami
slimani